a terrifying beast following its
instincts a hotel manager just trying to
get his job done great villains can get
you on their side no matter how evil
their schemes may be keep watching to
find out who made this list
comic book movies have often been
maligned as lacking in death offering
surface level takes on the human
experience at best black panther
represented a killer blow against that
argument however an academy award
nominee for best picture that trafficked
in serious political issues all while
celebrating african arts and history it
also introduced one of the most complex
villains in comic book movie history how
do you think your ancestors got these
you think they paid a fair price or did
they take it like they took everything
else
while t'challa ultimately assumes his
place as the king of wakanda eric
killmonger has a legitimate claim to the
throne and he's willing to fight for it
too the differences between the two men
are philosophical in nature and deeply
complicated killmonger doesn't feel that
the perfect land of wakanda should stay
isolated from the world when it could
use its substantial resources to fight
encroaching evil and organize a revolt
against the status quo t'challa's
approach is more noble and compassionate
so he inevitably wins out of course he
then allows the deadly climactic events
of avengers infinity war to take place
in wakanda something that likely
wouldn't have happened under
killmonger's regime
in the world of the karate kid karate is
a big deal in the valley area of
southern california and it's ruled over
by the kobrakai dojo and its star pupil
johnny lawrence johnny is a cocky
talented teenage martial artist willing
to do whatever it takes to win even
following the brutal war inspired
instructions of crease his cold and
devious sensei johnny's also got a
comfortable teen romance going with
classmate ali mills but then all of this
is threatened by daniel larusso a new
kid in town recently arrived from the
east coast who seems devoted to taking
away both johnny's karate dominance and
his girlfriend the karate kid presents
daniel's journey to find purpose and
stick up for himself against johnny and
his karate bully minions who do
admittedly deliver a sound and vicious
beating against their foe but as the
cobra kai series would later show johnny
had a lot of inner turmoil and plenty of
problems at home to boot he hates daniel
sure but that hatred only developed
after his adversary arrogantly moved in
on his world and his partner
starship troopers is a shoot-'em-up
sci-fi action movie with a dark side
it's set in the 23rd century where space
travel is easy enough that humanity has
entered into a new age of imperialism
and colonialism exploring and taking
over distant planets the united citizen
federation a fascistic global governing
body fueled by eerie war propaganda
becomes involved with the bugs an insect
alien species hellbends on destruction
i'm doing my part i'm doing my part i'm
doing my part
i'm doing my part too
but that's just the propaganda talking
it's only barely alluded to in the movie
but the reason the bugs are so insistent
on exterminating human space soldiers is
because the humans are hostile invaders
the united citizen federation tried to
conquer their planets their lands and
their homes in this sense the bugs are
only defending themselves and the humans
are the true villains of starship
troopers home alone was a massive
blockbuster success so a sequel was an
obvious next step but it would take some
creative thinking to duplicate the
unique circumstances that left kevin
mcallister alone at home and fending off
a gang of burglars home alone 2 lost in
new york finds kevin separated from his
family on a vacation alone in manhattan
and avoiding the recently escaped wet
bandits at the same time kevin runs
afoul of another grown-up mr hector the
sniveling concierge of the plaza hotel
portrayed by tim curry kevin checks into
the legendarily luxurious hotel and runs
up a massive bill on his non-present
father's credit card his every action in
charge rightfully arouses suspicion on
mr hector's part he's an employee of the
hotel after all and one who takes his
role very seriously he constantly
attempts to catch kevin in the act of
what is essentially identity theft and
fraud and is constantly foiled and
humiliated but mr hector is really just
trying to protect the hotel and its
assets against a rogue kid with a stolen
credit card
the santa claus is a classic modern day
christmas movie a cranky toy company
executive scott calvin attains the roles
and responsibilities of father christmas
after accidentally killing the real deal
on christmas eve the santa claus was
also one of the first family comedies to
explore the effects of divorce on
parents and their kids as he gives in to
his new role as santa claus and coming
to magically resemble the big guy
scott's ex-wife and her new husband neil
become increasingly concerned that scott
is having a mental breakdown neil is a
psychiatrist a modern man of the 90s who
is very much in touch with his emotions
because he's unlike the gruff macho and
blunt scots however and because he's
married to the mother of scots son scott
hates neil and so the audience is
supposed to hate neil too that's unfair
though because neil is just trying to
attend to the mental and social
well-being of his stepson and voices
concern for the boy's father at the same
time
hailed as the first summer blockbuster
and a horror classic draws as a
masterclass in anticipation tension and
terror set in the perfect beach resort
town of amity island the local community
is threatened when a shark begins
helping itself to a living buffet of
tasty meaty humans a skeleton crew of
salty hunters then heads out into the
ocean determined to kill the shark
before it can strike again they lie in
weight anticipating the attack and by
the time the credits roll one of the
crew is dead along with the shark itself
you could argue that hooper quaint and
brody were acting in preemptive
self-defense on behalf of amity but it's
also true that they were killing a
natural predator one who was merely
following its animal instincts sharks
need to eat meat to survive and the
beast in jaws simply found a lot of it
hanging around on a beach it didn't act
out of spite vengeance or some kind of
anti-human agenda the shark just did
what sharks are supposed to do
what killed the dinosaurs
the ice age
the batman films of the 80s and 90s
started out dark and became
progressively more cartoonish although
their villains grew ever more
sympathetic and the justifications for
their destructive actions became more
understandable in 1989's batman for
example jack nicholson's joker is a
campy over-the-top gleeful agent of
chaos by 1997's batman and robin
batman's rogue's gallery had been
exhausted to the point at which the
film's big bads were poison ivy and mr
freeze characters with very odd powers
and backstories more tragic than evil
botanist dr pamela eisley has a run-in
with her superior at a lab owned by
wayne enterprises and threatens to
squeal on his unauthorized development
of a dangerous drug for her reference dr
eisley is subjected to an attack using a
toxic substance adding insult to the
injury he indirectly caused bruce wayne
makes an enemy out of dr eisley when he
rejects her experimental environmental
projects meanwhile batman contends with
victor fries who has placed his wife
nora in deep freeze until he can cure
her life-threatening affliction poison
ivy unplugs nora's cryogenic unit and
tells frieza batman killed her tricking
the lovesick softy into becoming a
revenge bent villain named mr freeze
really though his heart is in the right
place
in john hughes team classic high school
dramedy the breakfast club there are six
main characters specifically five
teenagers and vice principal richard
vernon this creates a classic us vs them
dynamic between the young and optimistic
and the old and cynical those kids are
forced to spend their saturday in an
in-school suspension for various
infractions and rule violations with
vernon keeping a watchful eye on them
and offering a few snide comments in the
process in fact he generally behaves
more like a prison warden than an
administrator is vice principal vernon
the smug teen-hating jerk that john
hughes wrote him as and how paul gleeson
played him absolutely but vernon is
doing his job and then some he's also
using his saturday to discipline five
very special cases something he probably
didn't have to do in the first place he
obviously cares about students if he's
going to go the extra mile like this and
it bears mentioning that he's not just
randomly punishing bender claire brian
andrew and alison with the exception of
the latter who was kicking it in
detention by choice all of those
students did pretty bad stuff deserving
of the sentence one brought a gun to
school for example and another assaulted
a fellow student they're hardly heroes
based on a saturday night live sketch
about a cable access show shot in a
basement wayne's world is a self-aware
movie about the dangers of success and
the destructive appeal of fame it's a
thorough condemnation of selling out as
metalhead goofballs wayne and garth
learned after agreeing to let eubie
[ __ ] tv producer benjamin kane
turn their show into a commercial
network affair wayne and garth are
blindsided when the new wayne's world is
nothing like their old show with a new
theme song and heavy product placement
maybe i'm wrong on this one but for me
the beast doesn't include selling out
putting aside his villainous plan to
lure away wayne's girlfriend cassandra
benjamin is honest with his intentions
from his first appearance in the film he
sees the initial low rent wayne's world
on tv and starts making some calls about
acquiring the show and increasing its
reach he then gives wayne and garth a
contract that presumably lays out
everything he planned to do which they
happily sign benjamin is a ruthless
go-getter of a businessman sure but he
isn't the least bit evil or secretive
about any of his actions
in the many adaptations of rudyard
kipling's 1984 masterpiece the jungle
book and particularly in disney's 1967
animated musical adaptation shirkhan is
a main villain and fearsome king of the
jungle he's the most feared predator in
the land despite his innate coolness
charisma and persuasive nature he's also
a known hunter of humans which is
presented as the ultimate sin to a human
audience when you think about it though
that's not so much an intentional act of
evil as it is relatively normal behavior
for a carnivorous jungle cat yes shir
khan also genuinely hates humans but he
has his reasons for that too
as a dominant force and leader of the
jungle shiikan tries to protect his
environment and the animals that live in
it humans destroy the jungle and its
residents and he knows this hence why
shia khan is terrified of fire and how
the humans are able to wield it
both the incredibles and its sequel
incredibles 2 are movies about
physically gifted superheroes saving the
day but they're also clever satires of
the superhero film genre offering up
sharp commentary about societies and
drawing wish for god-like beings to rise
up and save us in the world of
incredibles 2 the cultural pendulum has
shifted to the point at which
superheroes have long fallen from grace
this leads tech giant winston dever and
his sister evelyn to recruit elastigirl
to regain the public's trust and faith
in superheroes however evel endeavour is
also the villain of the film under the
name screenslaver she devises a plan to
mass hypnotize superheroes and force
them to commit acts of evil and
destruction this is intended to
demonstrate how it's dangerous and then
wise to re-legalize supers a group that
could theoretically use their supreme
gifts for wicked purposes
evelyn really isn't a villain she's
simply pointing out that unchecked
privilege and unlimited power is the
true threat to society
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one